destiny 2 is kicking off its yearly
celebration of the game with moments of
triumph the free-to-play event is meant
to acknowledge all the milestones
achieved by players new and old alike
here's how the event works and how to
obtain the moments of triumph title and
seal the event itself begins now but
players will have plenty of time to
complete all the challenges and triumphs
requirements as moments of triumph won't
end until September 22nd which is a
release date for destiny to be on light
moments of triumph will require players
that go through various activities from
easy entry level bounty completions all
the way to the endgame raids the good
news is the event will reward players
along the way moments of triumph has
several in-game goodies to obtain such
as exotic ghost shells emblems and
exotic sparrows continue to accomplish
even more triumphs as you check them off
your list and you'll get special codes
to redeem at the Bungie store allowing
you to buy physical t-shirts and
memorabilia that are only available to
people who complete those triumphs now
there are numerous triumphs and the
whole list can seem daunting at first
especially when the MMX ex seal requires
28 of them some a little more concerning
to casual players than the rest rest
assured though that if you've been
playing even casually this season a lot
of your triumphs may have been retro
actively completed already although most
of the requirements for moments of
triumph are related to old events and
activities there are some triumphs
related to quest and story beats in the
season of arrivals that set up the next
expansion one particular triumph
involves obtaining all three of the
seasonal exotic weapons which means all
new exotic quests
one such quest is for the ruinous effigy
tracin rifle a void weapon that is
unlike anything Bungie has made in
destiny before the quest itself can be
tedious at times but we have a gameplay
guide to help streamline the fastest way
to obtain this exotic and the location
of several items you'll need to find in
a lengthy fetch quest arguably the
biggest change that moments of triumph
implements is the removal of a reward
cap on several old raids the Leviathan
eater of worlds spire of stars crown of
sorrow and scourge of the past raids are
all now farmable for their unique
weapons and
several of the triumphs are completing
these raids even include rewards that
were previously obtainable in raid but
had stingy drop rates one such example
being the luxurious toast remote which
is exclusive to the spire of Stars raid
now so long you beat the raid and claim
your triumph the reward is yours it's no
secret that several old locations from
vanilla destiny 2 are being removed from
the game temporarily with plans to
eventually rotate any vaulted content in
future seasons meaning that in just a
few months every Leviathan raid as well
as the scourge of the past will be
removed from the rotation for the time
being
this makes moments of triumph the
perfect time to fill out your
collections and obtain any armor sets or
weapons you may be missing from the
raids before they're taken out of the
rotation indefinitely
moments of triumph will eventually cross
over the solstice of Heroes another
seasonal event that also reap Rises and
encourages players to revisit old
activities and locations in celebration
there should be plenty of more surprises
and quests to look forward to as Bungie
begins to push forth on its most
ambitious expansion yet season of the
arrivals is truly the calm before the
storm and we're certain that there will
be so much to take in as beyond light
approaches closer so be sure to stick to
GameSpot as we'll have all the features
and guides and opinions you'll need for
dusting to
you